france 2 mais tout est loin d'être
gagnée pour les femmes c'est bien connu
le maire de diane aux marinas en italie
n'a rien trouvé de mieux que d'offrir
une semaine de vacances à toutes celles
qui afficheront les mensurations de
sophia loren délicate attention que nous
conte à l'achat apparemment la station
de diane aux marinas en italie à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de la
frontière française près de san remo ne
manque pas de clients le mètre carré y
vaut cher et non n'est jamais sûr de
trouver un coin pour poser sa serviette
seulement diano marina avec sa voie de
chemin de fer qui passe au ras des
vagues souffre d'un problème d'image
alors le maire grand amateur de femmes
devant l'éternel a eu une idée géniale
nous voudrions qu'à terme ils ne
viennent a dit anouck eu de très grands
très beau top model alors nous avons
cherché un critère objectif qui est
celui des mensurations classique disons
seul de la vénus de milo de sophia loren
90 60 90 ce sont les mensurations de
sophia loren
il a donc été décidé que toute femme
correspondant à ces critères se
verraient offrir une semaine de vacances
gratis adiahenot marina et notre merde
arpenter les plages de sa station m de
couturier à la main et de mesurer les
formes avantageuses des plus belles
naïades de diana beaucoup de candidats
mais peu d'élus 90-60-90 ça n'est pas si
banal en une journée entière de
tentatives notre mère n'a trouvé qu'une
héritière de sophia loren
tout cela pourrait n'être qu'un gag ou
une provocation
si cela ne correspondait pas havret
raisonnement commercial
abbiamo simplement s'amuser nous avons
toujours beaucoup de gens qui viennent
mais ce sont de plus en plus des
personnes âgées l'idée de 90 60 90 et
donc celle ci tenter de faire baisser
l'âge moyen des clients heureuses élues
du jour
mariam ne savait sans doute pas qu'elle
se prêtait en fait à une simple
opération de marketing